my first impression was this gate Kent
who this is the white kid redhead but
he's out there cooking it up and this
redheaded kid comes in the gym and you
notice him up his red hair first thing
he does jacks up a deep three and I
don't look like a good player in all
honesty he came in like with a swagger
though he knew he was that guy he had
this aura this confidence like I'm going
to kill you and now I'm adapt you up
after the game and we're cool but on the
court I'm a dog and I'm going to go
after you completely on the court is a
killer he has no friends on the court
unless you're on his team will go at you
he just tries to get the W and do
whatever he does have to get the W and
then he just shifted and then all of the
sudden he's on City League hoops and
he's getting a hundred thousand views
and then from then on we're just like
okay this kid's special once he blew up
like that I was like wow I mean it's
about to get serious for him I mean high
school basketball that social media
platform is crazy
at first it was cool I mean sometimes I
can get in the line you kind of just
have to deal with that I can't change
the fact that these people want pictures
I want autographs so I just I just have
to be nice and they treat me like one of
them which is I like that I don't want
to be treated any different but I mean
sometimes going to tournaments I'll have
to take pictures and sign stuff stuff
like that but I don't I wouldn't say a
celebrity no well he makes it a point to
make us feel like were the ones with
300,000 followers we're getting a
million views and were signing
autographs every 5 minutes every place
that we go people you know go ask him
for pictures and stuff like I don't even
think of him as a celebrity just another
friend of me so you can just kind of see
that's like kind of eye-opening and you
know I never expected one of my friends
to be that well known throughout the
country even if I'm having a bad day if
that little kid wants a picture I'm not
gonna say no I can't say no I have to
take time out of my day and make sure I
make his day they don't care that he's a
youtube sensation a viral sensation they
don't care that you're a redheaded mom
like don't care about none of that we
all try to make it where it's like
you're still Nico you still gotta go to
school you gotta put your pants on like
the rest of us I just think that the
typical standard that they give him
redheaded white kid in this score and
he's just gonna get all this hype and
attention but like just with you
and your craft they don't see the work
that you put in they don't see the
effort and the time and the management
and the things that you do behind the
scenes I feel like if I look different
that still I still get the same
attention because it's really about the
stuff I do on the floor and not not what
I look like
[Applause]
what's up you guys it's Taylor Brooks
with bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for more video content